I have lived long enough to see the same
eyes in different people
I see your eyes
I know your eyes
me
Star Wars The Force awakens
who are you
and no one
follow me
nothing must urban our work
I'll show the dark side
I don't know your name
Finn what's yours
I'm right
you might need this
Star Wars The Force awakens
the force is strong in my family
my father has it
I have it
my sister has it
you have that power too
Chewie we're all
you
real sets practical effects you've been
here but you don't know this story
nothing's changed really I mean
everything's changed but nothing's
changed that's the way you want it to be
really to sync the way the technology
has evolved and yet keeping one foot in
the pre-digital world
it couldn't be more exciting it's still
surreal we are here on day 1 of Star
Wars Episode 7 yeah yeah how incredible
I can die now all right my whole life
has led to this moment
I think we've worn the suit out probably
quicker than we expected because every
time you meet someone they just want to
hug it get back to the old days the old
ways of doing things
JJ is trying to make sure these movies
have a physicality to them we truly are
out in a desert a real desert I'm just
gonna bring carrots it's a knife you
don't get to feel the next wing every
day or a Millennium Falcon every day I
come to work smiling you have to pause
take a breath slow down and really not
freak out
I was in the same room as all these
legends and with all these new people
who are sure born to be legends
themselves you know it's being done with
such love and such enthusiasm from
everybody and I think that you'll be
able to feel that coming off the screen
it means so much as so many people
you just know what's gonna be like in
the cinema star was just an important
part of everyone's history it's a
beautiful thing to actually be involved
in it
who are you
I'm no one
I was raised to do one thing
I've got nothing to fight for nothing
will stand in our way
I will finish
would you start
there are stories about what happened
it's true
the dark side
Oh Jedi
they're real
the force it's calling to you
just editing
there's been an awakening have you felt
it
it's a dog side and the light
who are you I'm no one
where do you come from I know all about
waiting for my family
I will fulfill our destiny I will finish
what you started
I don't know your name Finn all right
there were stories about what happened
of course
it's true all I
hope is not lost today it is found
not that monster